we continue now with our special report
on art theft we just heard from the FBI
but sometimes in fact oftentimes it
takes more than someone with a badge and
a gun to get to the bottom of the case
in the movies like the Thomas Crown
Affair art thieves are portrayed as
cultured and debonair as they make off
with priceless treasures but we got a
different take on that criminal industry
from this man Christopher Robinson a
former art dealer who now works as a
lawyer helping clients including museums
and collectors recover stolen art or
find out if they've been sold fakes we
talked with him at the Jill Newhouse
gallery in New York City in the movies
we see Thomas Crown the debonair
cultured art see is that what our
thieves are no I don't think so I think
it's possible that from time to time
there's one or two people who will
Commission a theft like that for those
kinds of purposes but for the most part
it's it's a way of making some money and
actually it's a very bad way of making
money because this is not a liquid asset
we just heard from the head of the FBI
art theft squad that they're still
looking for the arts told from the
Gardner Museum after almost 30 years is
it realistic to think that can ever be
seen again I think so
I mean there's no way of knowing for
sure but those paintings are so valuable
that I really do feel they'll be found
feel that they will be found again that
one of the main issues though is in what
condition I suspect will they be moved
around a fair amounts it's the theft and
there's always a risk of damage to them
over that period of time can art that
that's well know known to have been
stolen can it ever be sold is that is
there a market for it not a legitimate
market I mean there's no way that could
be sold at an auction or or you know in
a regular private way I mean I suspect
that those have those paintings if they
do still exist have passed hands so
there's some form of collateral either
for some for arms for money in some kind
money laundering of some kind and that
would be the normal way that that would
be used because I think the
understanding is that there's there's no
way those works can exit into the
legitimate market is there a way that
doesn't involve law enforcement to
recover that
of stolen art there are private
companies that that can work on this I
know that if you are a private
individual and you've had a theft there
are companies that can that can work on
this for you
k2 is one I know that does a lot of
investigative work in this area the art
loss register also which has a very
important database of lost works of art
can also be and will also take on an
issue like this to try and find the
works and what about the idea of a
reward or a ransom is that helpful
does it encourage future thefts no I
think a reward is helpful the reward is
going to be probably aimed at a minor
player in all of this for whom it's
going to be a lot of money and I don't
think that those are the people who are
going to be looking for that reward and
not those that stole the work in the
first place here's a question from our
executive producer Rhonda Schwartz Chris
my question for you is about the stolen
Gardner art where do you think it is do
you think it's in the hands of some
wealthy collector who's got it hidden
away in his house in his basement who's
secretly looking at it where do you
think it is I don't think it's like that
I very very much doubt it's on display
anywhere to anybody
these paintings I think often end up
getting packed up buried put in outside
storehouses somewhere it's possible it's
in a free port somewhere the free ports
around the world are very little
regulated and it's very difficult
sometimes to know what's in there and
those are secure ways of keeping art of
this kind and how do you feel about it
when you see that kind of art cultural
values and treasure stone I think it's
horrible obviously anybody with a with a
mind would think that that is a horrible
thing to happen these paintings are on
public view for a reason they're there
for the public to enjoy they're part of
our cultural patrimony and when they're
stolen like that especially if there's a
risk that they're going to get damaged
it's a terrible thing
do you have clients who get offered this
stolen art and how do you make sure it's
legit I hope I don't have clients who
get off of this kind of art I've never
been told by them if they
have the the way that a private client
needs to do his due diligence find out
if the work is right or not you can you
start off with a very simple google you
can contact some basic databases the Art
Loss Register based in London keeps a
very good database of art that has been
stolen around the world you can inquire
through Interpol as well there are there
are and also the arm eye far the
International Foundation for art
research in New York keeps good tabs on
what work has been stolen so with the
internet it's even harder than ever to
pass stolen art I think it's become
almost impossible unless it's something
a relatively relatively generic or minor
you might get a 19th century landscape
or maybe an Italian or master painting
by nobody in particular and that's the
kind of work that will be difficult to
pin down because you may not have an
author and you may not have a an image
that is very memorable that art still
continues to be stolen it does I mean
it's it's a great temptation especially
when you see the kinds of prices that
arts bet our fetchers at auction four
hundred and something million dollars
for the Leonardo it obviously is a great
temptation booster for others and thank
you very much you're welcome